[Music]  that is Soundgarden's dynamic frontman  Chris Cornell singing the band's classic  black hole Sun and we lost one of  music's great 20 unexpectedly took his  own life last night in Detroit the  two-time Grammy winner helped create and  define a whole genre of music the so  called Seattle sound and we were lucky  enough to spend time with Chris over the  years it's a dream come true a little  kid from Seattle being able to do this  is wonderful  Chris leaves behind a wife Vicki and  three kids one of whom daughter Toni was  often by his side are you excited yeah  why because our daddy how proud are you  of that I'm extremely proud good friend  Brad Pitt made a rare public appearance  after splitting from Angelina to  introduce a performance back in January  I'm a huge fan of mr. Chris Cornell  [Applause]  [Music]  Chris Cornell was just 52 years old  you